Julien, JW, it's come down
to France and the United States
in our first ever
international competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
Are you ready to see what it is?
Not ready.
Well, that weapon is--
the spadroon.
All right, bladesmiths.
Good luck.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
JULIEN: I'm happy to
be home in France.
Look at the nice view behind us.
It's magnificent.
So I start to make my tip,
but I have to be really fast.
Because more you hit your
blade, less carbon you have.
[clanking]
it's like music.
[french] music.
I love to do some
music with my hammer.
(SINGING) Dum, dum, pick it up.
Dum, dum, pick it up.
It just gets you some rhythm.
It's just more fun.
Today I did it all--
turned the tip, the blade.
All I have left is to
grind it a little bit.
And it's going very well.
Boom!
JW: Well, I'm excited to
get started this morning.
Fixing to start
profiling everything,
so I'm going to spend a bunch
of time at the grinder today.
With the length of
this blade, I mean,
it's like grinding three
10-inch Bowie knives.
You've got a ton of work.
Just getting everything
rough ground out.
We're just about ready to
go to heat treat on it,
so right now would be
time for a little prayer.
Now, the grinding process was
slower than I would have liked
for it to be, so this
is a short amount
of time left to heat treat.
[music playing]
[torch]
I notice this curve from the top
down, and it just heart sinks.
I've got to do something
to correct this.
I know I can't fix it cold,
so we've got to go back in
and heat treat again.
I take it out of the oil
and I got that same thing.
And I'm thinking I'm going
have to regroup and start over.
JULIEN: So today,
I'm going to work
to be ready for the quench.
The quench is important because
if the quench is not good,
my blade's going
to be like butter,
and she's going to
bend at the first shot.
[music playing]
I think it bent.
Oh, [bleep].
I know that there's a weak point
on my blade to make the curve,
so I have to do a second one.
[music playing]
[burning]
[whistle]
Boom.
Third quench.
This one goes down, I don't
want to do another one.
[music playing]
[whistle]
We have to make another blade.
I have to restart everything.
[clanking]
I don't want to
do another blade.
But I've got my
country behind me,
so I have to show
them that I respect
them, and give the best.
Yeah.
I thought about a lot,
what happened yesterday.
I've got plenty to work with.
But I still got a slight
curve in the spine,
so what I'm going to have
to do is grind that away.
[music playing]
Going good.
As I'm grinding, I can tell that
this thing is going to be OK.
What a huge relief that is.
And now that this
plate issue is fixed,
I can focus on fit and finish.
What's challenging about it is
hitting the sizing right on it.
Instead of having
a round handle,
we're going to have
an oval handle.
There's just nothing
comfortable about a round
handle when you're striking
something on an angle.
Done deal.
I've got real high
expectations of it.
I really do.
I think it's going to do well.
Bladesmiths, to find out
how lethal your weapons are,
I will deliver some slashes and
thrusts on these big carcasses.
Julien, you're up first.
You ready?
I think so.
[laughing]
[music playing]
[slashing]
All right, Julien, let's
talk about your sword here.
It's a bit on the heavier side.
Your edge easily lacerates
into the big carcass.
On the thrust, it
penetrates deep.
Your weapon definitely is sharp.
Your sword will kill.
Thank you.
JW, you're next.
You ready?
Think so.
[music playing]
[slashing]
OK, JW.
Let's talk about
your spadroon, here.
The fact that you put a fuller
all the way through up here
lightened your sword a lot.
It is so sharp,
it almost cut all
the way through this carcass.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Thank you, Doug.
Now, Donald McBane, who
wrote the book on this weapon,
called it the shearing sword.
So to test the sharpness
of your blades,
I'll be chopping
through this rope,
and then attacking these
sandbags as they fall.
Julien you're up.
Are you ready?
Oui.
OK.
[slashing]
[music playing]
Whew!
I'll get him.
[slashing]
[music playing]
[sand spilling]
JULIEN: Yes.
It's good.
Good job.
It's breaking good.
Well, Julien, that's sharp.
It passed right
through the ropes.
through the bags.
But the weight in this sword,
and the shape of its handle,
just have a tendency to
be very hard to stop.
A little thinner
handle, possibly.
A little more indexed--
JULIEN: Yeah.
--would have helped.
But it's definitely
a sharp sword.
Thank you very much.
Sir, you are next.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
[slashing]
[music playing]
[sand spilling]
Definitely sharp enough
to cut through the ropes.
Your handle, would have
been nice to see it taper
and swell a little bit more,
but it's definitely a cutter.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Nicely done.
All right, gentlemen.
Next up is the strength test.
Now, to test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'll be thrusting with the
tip and cutting these hardwood
leather-wrapped shields.
JW, you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
[chopping]
Well, everything on
the blade looks good.
Guard's still tight.
Handle hasn't moved.
I think you did a great job.
Thank you, Dave.
Julien, are you ready?
Good luck.
[chopping]
[music playing]
So, Julien, you've got
a very stout edge profile.
Blade's still straight.
Well done.
Thank you so much.
Well, gentlemen.
The judges have
made their decision.
Our very first "Forged in Fire"
International Champion is JW.
Congratulations, you are
our first "Forged In Fire"
International Champion.
Julien--
Oui?
Unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
J. Neilson will explain.
J. NEILSON: Julien, you
brought us a beautiful piece.
But compared to your competitor,
your blade was a lot heavier
in the front, balance-wise.
And with that round
handle, it made it a lot
harder control in the testing.
That's why we're
going to let you go.
Julien, say finis, mon ami.
Please surrender your weapon.
OK.
Thank you, guys.
I'm very proud of this
blade, but JW's a god.
He's a god in the forge.
And this guy is my friend.
JW, the American, and
our very first "Forged
in Fire" International Champion.
It's a title that also comes
with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Please present your
weapon to the judges.
I put forth a lot of
hard work, time, and effort
to reach this point.
So it's just been an
incredible honor to be
asked to represent my country.
And not only that, but
being able to meet guys
from different parts of the
world, and the friendships
that we developed, was
just a great experience.
And that's what it's all about.
[music playing]